well Amazon's - button don't just help  you order things they can also collect  and organize data with a little  programming skill cloud stitch CTO Ted  Benson turned his Huggies - button into  a system to log information about his  baby the hack is pretty simple each -  button is made up of a Wi-Fi radio and a  battery when you press the button it  connects to your Wi-Fi network  Benson loves each time the button  connected to Wi-Fi by linking it to a  Google spreadsheet while he's using the  hack to log his baby's dirty diapers  Benson says connecting to the buttons  Wi-Fi could allow users to do almost  anything  Amazon unveiled his - button in March of  this year the device costs just five  dollars